Kevin Bacon had just come off diner and
I had seen diner like 11 times great
movie I doubt his abs the times her
diner and I had it on my walls
fair to say you had a crush on him I was
mad for him right and then when I got
the job I would go on my bicycle every
day we were in Utah I would get
groceries and I would knock on
everybody's door in the motel we were
staying at the Rodeway Inn and Provo and
I would knock on Kevin Bacon's door and
I would say you need any groceries I'm
headed to the you know the whatever
Jigar Albertsons I would do anything
trying desperately to get a relationship
going no he had a he had a girlfriend
but you look a loved if Kevin Bacon was
your man that was your type I loved him
loved him loved him when you work with
these like a Steve Martin and you work
with Nick Cage as an actor do you fall
in love with these people that's part of
this magic that can or sometimes doesn't
happen is that sort of like time
suspends everything else stops outside
this experience and and the world is our
alternate universe yes and you're not
yourself and you're contractually
obligated to fall in love with this
other person to kiss them to be intimate
and you're working late and you're
hanging out and there's a it's a very
seductive it is otherworldly environment
and it makes perfect sense that people
are constantly falling in and out of
love on movie sets